it gives me great pleasure to welcome
the 2021
graduates of the ohsu biomedical
informatics graduate program
to this year's virtual commencement
ceremony
i never thought we would have a second
virtual commencement this year
but the pandemic is not yet fully behind
us
with more and more people getting
vaccinated each day however
i'm confident that next year's ceremony
will be in person
and i hope ohsu finds a way for those
participating
virtually the last couple years to take
part in person in some way
if nothing else we will celebrate next
year at the annual demise banquet
around graduation time that all alumni
are always invited to attend
i do miss the pomp and circumstance of
graduation
and getting to wear regalia and march in
the procession
as many of you know the annual
commencement ceremony is an important
event for me
as i enjoy every year celebrating the
success of our graduates and they're
moving on to new paths in their lives
we have been awarding degrees and
certificates from our program since 1998
and only once have i had to miss
commencement
in any case most of you are now moving
from your studies into jobs where the
contributions of informatics are more
critical than ever
just as the pandemic has exposed
problems in our health care system
it has also exposed limitations in our
data and information systems
it is critical for all informatics
graduates
and everyone else in the informatics
field to keep improving how we use data
and information
not only to overcome covit19 but also to
improve health
health care public health and biomedical
research
generally from bio to imaging to
clinical and public health informatics
the challenges have never been greater
i'm confident however that you all have
the talent
and the knowledge and skills you have
acquired in your studies to meet those
challenges
i am pleased to report with the 33 of
you graduating today
our program has now awarded over 900
degrees and certificates
dating back to 1998. these include
398 master's degrees and 34 phd
degrees our graduates have achieved
success
in academia industry government and just
about every other place where
informaticians work
your success is one of the main aspects
of our work
that give faculty and staff great
satisfaction
let me close as always to remind you
that even though you are moving on from
ohsu and d mice
we are still here for you and hope you
will keep in touch with us as your
careers develop
and prosper